In the good old times,
people learned how to read and to write.
That's no longer sufficient in the high
tech 21st century.
We also need to know how to deal with
risk and uncertainty and that is what I
mean with risk savvy.
Here's a simple example.
You hear on the where's the report could
there's a 30% chance of rain tomorrow,
30% chains of what now?
I live in Berlin and most Belinda's
believe that it means that it will rain
in 30% of the time.
That is seven to eight hours as a think.
It will rain in 30% of the region.
Most New Yorkers belief,
that's all nonsense.
It means it will rain on 30% of the days
for rich.
This prediction has been made that is
most likely not at all.
Many psychologists think that people
can't learn how to deal with risk,
but in this case it's the experts do
meteorologists.
We have not learned how to communicate
risk in an understandable way.
That is to say to what class?
The 30% refers time or region or days.
And if you have some imagination you can
think of what other classes.
For instance,
one woman in New York said,
I know what 30% means,
three meteorologist think it rains and
seven not now getting soaked isn't minor
risk,
but I'll be risk savvy when it comes to
more important things.
For instance,
20 year olds drive,
we still cell phone glued to their ears
not realizing that the decrees,
their reaction time to that of a 70 year
old or many Americans,
about 20% believe that they are in the
top 1% income group and as many believed
it will be soon be there or take health.
So about an estimated 1 million children
get every year unnecessary computed
tomography.
CT scans
unnecessary because they're not really
clinically indicated,
which is not just a waste of time but
also danger to the kids because a ct
scan can have the radiation of a hundred
chest x rays and may lead in a small
number of these kids later to cancer.
We deal everyday with risks but we
haven't learned how to understand them.
And the problem is not simple in the
human mind,
but also in experts who is a,
don't know what the risks are or don't
know how to communicate them or in other
areas,
like if it's about finance or health,
have interests other than yours.
So the key message you stays,
everyone can learn to deal with risks.
In that case,
everyone can learn to ask the question,
probability of what.
And second,
if you believe that are safe by young
delegating the responsibility of your
Wilson and health to experts,
then you may be disappointed because
many experts
do not know how to communicate
probabilities or,
uh,
tried to protect themselves against you
as in health care as a potential
plaintiff.
So you have to think yourself.
And that's the key message.